all right so there is a pushback against
vaccine mandates and it is a beautiful
thing people
human beings free citizens in these
united states of america are saying i
want to make decisions for myself i
don't want the government and a bunch of
unaccountable bureaucrats to tell me
what i have to do with my life my
privacy my medical records and my
medical history
is my business and my doctor's business
this is all good stuff and we've seen a
push back from southwest airlines
employees we've seen a push back from uh
from now from in and out which we'll get
to in just a sec and a huge push back
now from chicago cops over 3
000 of them
are now pushing back against lori
lightfoot's vaccine mandate got about a
minute it's worth the video for you at
least two memos have gone out since
friday's deadline but this morning the
head of the police union says officers
are holding the line the unofficial
number we have is about over 3 200 so
about a third of the department fop
president john conzar says that's the
number of officers who haven't complied
with the city's order to report their
vaccination status to an online portal
he says those officers will be getting
called in today and once again they'll
be asked to do so if they refuse it
sounds like they're going to go into a
no-pay status effective immediately
kanzar says this is no longer about the
vaccine or personal beliefs but about
collective bargaining rights all of
those things are a change in your
employment
policies you have to negotiate with us
what that looks like the city has
refused to do that two memos have been
sent out since friday the latest from
sunday involves consequences officers
could face if they don't follow the city
of chicago's vaccination policy that
officer will become a subject of a
disciplinary investigation that could
quote result in a penalty up to and
including separation from the chicago
police department the memo goes on to
say that sworn members of the department
who retire while under an investigation
may be denied retirement credentials on
saturday a different memo was sent out
it says days off now require approval
from a deputy chief or above cpd hasn't
said if this is related to the ongoing
tension between the police union and
mayor lori lightfoot over the city's
vaccine mandate but as of now the union
is not budging
our moniker all week has been hold the
line for a reason hold the line that's
right whether you're in a union or
whether you're an individual trying to
make some decisions for yourself there's
so much interesting stuff there now of
course already you get my feelings on
vaccine mandates okay fine now i get it
that the police are part of the
government they're not part of the
federal government in this case they're
part of the chicago the city government
potentially the state government of
illinois but these people are trying to
make a statement for themselves now
what's really interesting about this is
what uh the representative talks about
there that this affects their collective
bargaining so they go in and they
negotiate their contracts and
retirements and salaries and benefits
and all of these things and now the
state in essence is just trying to
change that right in front of them and
you heard that this could affect their
retirement they could take days off from
them suspend them you know take away pay
all sorts of stuff so i just want to be
very clear i stand a hundred percent uh
with these officers in chicago and by
the way
chicago does need officers if you think
for a moment that chicago can afford to
lose
about 3
three thousand two hundred police
officers out of about nine thousand
roughly a third of them uh well they
can't there were three people killed in
chicago this weekend 41 wounded in
shootings
across chicago we've got a graphic that
we'll play next time we've been working
on a graphic for chicago shootings we
just haven't covered it in a while this
flew at us at the last second but the
point is these people need more police
not less police and yes you know
everywhere they cut police bad things
happen less police more crime that's how
it works logic reason yippity-dippity-do
uh it's just bananas so i stand with
those people and again this is how we
will fight back don't think that even
donald trump or some other republican
you love or or even ron desantis ron
desantis because he's a governor right
now he's intimately involved in this and
he's doing an incredible job in florida
making sure that these mandates won't
stick and making sure people have choice
but even ron desantis can't save you if
you live in florida it still will come
down to you and how you will live your
life and what you will do at your place
of business and where you work and all
of those things
and to that point speaking of places
that could use some more policing in san
francisco a local in and out franchise
is fighting the power the city of san
francisco temporarily closed an in and
out fast food restaurant over the
company's refusal to force customers to
prove that they are vaccinated against
the coronavirus we refuse to become the
vaccination police for any government
whenzing or declared slamming the san
francisco department of health's
requirements as unreasonable invasive
and unsafe and accusing the city of
asking restaurants to segregate
customers based on vaccine documentation
we fiercely disagree with it with any
government dictate that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business this statement said this is
clear governmental overreach and is
intrusive improper and offensive the
store has since reopened but indoor
dining is not available so as far as i
know oh so it not a franchise okay so
i'm getting some info i like this i like
getting info on the fly so in and out
are not franchised they are all owned by
the parent in and out company
uh still operated still owned and
operated by the snyder family so that's
pretty fantastic i actually thought they
were a franchise so that's really
interesting so normally when it's a
franchise it's like you're licensing the
in and out logo and all the stuff
but you own it this is all owned by one
family so god bless these people they're
saying hey this is government overreach
it's not our job to do i suspect that
they're not forcing their employees to
be vaccinated but making some decisions
for themselves and by the way once you
make that decision as a as a
as a business especially
a fast food joint where people are
coming and going a lot it's like people
then can make the choice oh i don't want
to go there or i do want to go there
because they're in line with my values
or
i'm afraid of going there because i'll
die you might make these choices so
that's the beauty of what freedom is and
yeah it's a little messy but it's a hell
of a lot better than the alternative